et plusieurs associations dévoile ce
mardi leur plan de sortie de crise
dans cette tribune les organisations
comme attac la cgt créer une piste
france ou oxfam défendent 34 mesures
dans les domaines sanitaires sociaux
économiques et écologiques
le 27 mars dernier si les associations
avaient déjà publié un document intitulé
plus jamais ça appelant à construire le
monde est d'après et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec raphaël prado
porte parole d'attac france
monsieur prado à bonjour merci à d'être
avec moi alors tout le monde parle du
monde d'après vous aussi dans cette
tribune au monde avant coronavirus et un
monde après qu un navire ne sait ce qui
va se passer aujourd'hui en france et
dans le monde entier
cette crise elle a révélé un certain
nombre de problèmes qui étaient déjà là
avant la question qui se pose maintenant
c'est est ce qu'on continue comme avant
où est-ce qu'on profite de cette crise
pour bifurquer
on a voulu avec se planquer jossien
quand même très ambitieuse ne serait ce
que par le nombre d'organisations qui
sont représentées ainsi quand même pas
pour ans de se mettre d'accord sur un
texte avec des revendications aussi
festive avec des organisations
syndicales comme la cgt fsu solidaires
la confédération paysanne ou avec des
aux situations aussi diverses que
attaque aux femmes
les amis de la terre ou greenpeace et
donc c'est vrai qu'on a eu tendance ces
dernières décennies à opposer le social
et l'écologique et là où on veut
démontrer au contraire qu'il est
possible de sortir de cette crise par le
haut en bifurquant et en faisant en
sorte qu'il ait pas de retour à la
normale puisque le monde avant tel qu'il
était malheureusement n'est pas
soutenable
ce que vous voulez dire c'est que cette
crise sanitaire elle a accéléré ce monde
après bien disons qu'elle rend encore
plus urgente une bifurcation ont fait un
certain nombre de propositions qui a la
foi relève de l'urgence mais aussi qui
permet de préparer le monde après vous
parliez à l'instant du plan de relance
pour pour l'automobile
on a parlé ya pas très longtemps d'être
derrière france nous on considère par
exemple qui n'est pas n'est pas normal
de bd les entreprises polluantes sans
contrepartie et qu'il faut au contraire
profiter de cette situation pour les
obliger à se soumettre un certain nombre
d'impératifs écologique et notamment de
respecter les accords de paris alors
vous l'avez dit un green peace oxfam
france attac cgt tous en effet sont
d'accord que ce soit des groupes sociaux
écologiques qui sont d'accord pour
refonder un système un système qui est
selon-vous selon saurait plus juste plus
équitable plus vers mai
gouvernement est ce que lui il est prêt
à refonder ce système justement on voit
bien que la tentation du gouvernement
c'est nous dire on va recommencer comme
avant
voir on va continuer la casse sociale en
bois notamment sa tentation qui est très
fort de dire c'est les salariés qui vont
payer la crise ne lui disent pas de
cette manière là avait il dit pour
relancer la croissance il va falloir
travailler plus on à remettre en cause
des 35 heures on pense qu'au contraire
cessé
il faut changer de logiciel alors dans
les différentes mesures qu'on propose
vous avez des mesures d'urgence
la gratuité des masses qui vous allez
aussi des mesures comme un plan
d'urgence pour l'hôpital cette crise a
montré que sa liste publique ont besoin
de moyens supplémentaires
on a aussi puisque on a beaucoup entendu
depuis ce matin des critiques consistant
à dire qu'en gros on voudrait raser
gratis et on fait plein de propositions
on augmente les salaires on diminue le
temps de travail et comment est-ce qu'on
va financer tout ça on a aussi des
mesures pour financer cela est d'une
manière qui est plus juste aujourd'hui
notamment en renforçant la progressivité
d'impôt sur le revenu en recréant un
impôt sur la fortune en supprimant les
niches fiscales inutiles en luttant
contre l'évasion fiscale
donc c'est sûr que le gouvernement lui
n'a pas l'intention de changer le
logiciel même si on voit dans la
communication que macro nous dit oui je
me suis trompé il va falloir arrêter de
casser l'hôpital public et et nous ce
qu'on dit c'est justement il est temps
d'engager un rapport de forces c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est mis toutes ses
organisations autour de la table
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas manifester on
peut pas se mobiliser dans la rue
par contre on peut peser dans le débat
public et c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
avec
avec ce plan de sortie de crise et ses
34 mesure que je vous invite à retrouver
sur différents sites
alors très rapidement messieurs pas d'où
est ce que vous pensez qu'on est arrivé
au bout du système actuel ben on arrive
et on peut toujours continuer dans le
mur en accélérant et en klaxonnant mais
abandonner le choc a été violent et
cette crise a été un choc violent qui
révèle un certain nombre de
contradictions notamment dont on peut
pas continuer la mondialisation comme
avant un show se développe quelques
exemples là dessus on considère qu'il
est urgent de stopper les accords de
libre échange
alors que pendant la période du
confinement la commission européenne a
continué à négocier des nouveaux accords
de libre échange on l'entend partout qui
affola relocaliser l'économie nous ont
dit oui il faut relocaliser l'économie
pour ça ça veut dire qu'il faut arrêter
de développer les accords de libre
échange on a aussi par exemple beaucoup
entendu parler des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en termes
d'agriculture là c'est le moment c'est
l'occasion d'engager un vaste plan de
transition de l'agriculture et
d'alimentation pour la rendre à la fois
plus écologique et plus sociale monsieur
prado à merci d'avoir été en direct avec
moi je rappelle que vous êtes porte
parole d'attac france attac france qui
fait partie de la vingtaine
d'organisations qu'à signer un plan de
sortie de crise merci